so guys so panel i've been trying to
raise thirty thousand pounds and guess
what three days ago and i just got a
chance to do this video now because i've
been really big as go to london somebody
donated fifteen thousand
four hundred pounds
fifteen thousand four hundred pounds and
i met my target immediately but we
raised the bar to now forty thousand
pounds may allah bless this person and
give them the best in this life and here
after fifteen thousand four hundred
pounds it doesn't matter what you give
how small or large it's the intentions
behind the brothers and sisters i want
you guys to control help me reach 40 000
pounds we are just about five just over
five thousand pounds away brothers and
sisters you guys can do inshallah may
allah bless every single one of you guys
who gave one pound to give 50p to the
one who's given 15 400 pounds two in
between every one of you guys make this
happen
it's for syria afghanistan and ethiopia
people are freezing to death brothers
and sisters inshallah we ask allah to
purify attention accept it from us let's
reach the target of forty thousand
inshallah